[Music]
oh look at this this is a good one some
suggest that parker's powers include the
male spider's ability to hypnotize
females stop come on yes my spider lord
can we just like stay up here all day it
is so crazy down there
that's right folks spiderman is in fact
peter parker listen i did not kill
mysterio the drones did the drones that
are yours
does any part of you feel relieved about
all this what do you mean
now that everybody knows you don't
really have to hide or lie to people for
the record i never wanted to lie to you
but how do you tell someone that you're
spider-man
now everybody knows
but this isn't about me this is hurting
a lot of people
i've just been thinking about how to fix
all of this
so peter
why do i owe the pleasure i'm sorry to
bother you sir please we saved half the
universe together i think we're beyond
you calling me sir okay stephen
that feels weird but i'll allow it
when mysterio revealed my identity my
entire life got screwed up
i was wondering if maybe you could make
it so that he never did
strange don't cast that spell
it's too dangerous
fine
i won't
the entire world is about to forget that
peter parker is spider-man wait everyone
can't some people still know that's not
how the spell works
so mj's gonna forget about everything
we've ever been through stop tampering
with the spell oh my god ned he's my
best friend oh my aunt may should really
stop talking
what just happened
we tampered with the stability of space
time
multiverse is a concept about which we
know frighteningly level
the problem is you trying to live two
different lives
the longer you do it the more dangerous
it becomes
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter
[Music]
you